I want my skincare full of chemicals and
without free from claims here's why
everything is made of chemicals here's
what's in blueberries there are some
complicated names like true methyl
butyraldehyde which I'm sure a lot of
people can't pronounce but blueberries
are healthy free from Clays are
misleading yes you should avoid
ingredients if you're allergic but if
it's fine for the vast majority of
people it's usually there for marketing
purposes for example right now way more
people are allergic to methyl
isothiazolanone or Mi than parabens but
paraben free is a much more common claim
than am I free even though that would be
helpful for a lot more people for both
those of us who are allergic can just
check the ingredients list the big issue
with unhelpful free-form claims is that
it reinforces the false idea that these
ingredients are bad for everyone and not
using them is some sort of selling point
Mi allergies Rose in a lot of places
after paraben free became a common claim
and there's a good chance they're
related they're both preservatives
products need preservatives to keep
bacteria and mold in check they've been
seeing less and less products with
parabens and more and more with MI